I was hanging with Carolina Panthers
running that Christian McCaffrey who is
really looking forward to Super Bowl
Sunday he teamed up with Christian and
Verizon to see how they're building the
most powerful 5g experience to enhance
the way we live work and play and
powering the first 5g Super Bowl okay so
tell me now what does it do for a fan
like me as a fan you have your phone
here and you got your TV you you click
on on a certain player it'll zoom in on
the player it'll tell you where he went
to school it'll tell you how fast he ran
and you can you can see the game from an
end zone cam from a side cam from aerial
view and I heard that they also will
have the stadium's hooked up for five
genes you can click on on you know
different things and see how how long
the line is for the bathroom what's the
best way to get to your parked car
Verizon is also encouraging fans to
volunteer challenging them to commit the
same amount of time they spend watching
football to doing good
fans can visit give one more Sunday comm
to find out where they can do good
locally and share Verizon's related
videos using the hashtag one more sunday
anytime you can increase and enhance the
ability to give back and make it easier
make it more fun make it so more people
can do it you know you're doing a good
thing
[Music]